la historia de héctor word en un minuto
esta es la historia de kratos el cargo
más fuerte y enojado de los videojuegos
gratos es un prodigioso guerrero
espartano que como buen espartano se
dedica a arreglar los problemas a los
puntazos
pero un día para salvar su vida hace un
trato con el dios de la guerra ares a
quien le vende su alma a cambio de poder
pero pronto se daría cuenta de su error
pues por culpa de los engaños de ares
kratos enceguecido por la ira termina
asesinando a su esposa e hija por
accidente kratos se recontra cabrea y
decide acabar con ares y como la mayoría
de dioses del olimpo también quieren
hacer carnitas ares deciden ayudar a
gatos durante un largo viaje hasta que
finalmente kratos se encuentra la caja
de pandora la abre y se vuelve recontra
poderoso gigante imax jaime de esta
manera logra matar a ares y kratos se
convierte en el nuevo dios de la guerra
o algo así